[Musique]
des sardes à queue jaune des corps ou
des éponges une faune riche
représentatif de toute la côte caraïbe
nous sommes dans la commune du cardé au
lieu-dit le résigner
[Musique]
la zone connu par les amateurs de
plongée grâce à l'épave du navire la
moby s'étend sur une surface de nectar
et commence tout juste à retrouver des
couleurs fortes baisses de fréquentation
de la zone là on commence à observer une
procuration elle est très lente très
faibles donc pour le moment la zone et
disons en train de guérir petit à petit
et le but de celle de la laisser gérer
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit complètement
rétabli
des panneaux de signalisation des
coffres d'amarrage pour protéger cet
espace même dispositif pour la zone du
petit ou situe entre la pointe marouba
et la pompe au dessus ici aussi toutes
les formes de pêche sont désormais
interdites mais également la crèche des
bateaux les infractions peuvent être
lourdes et des infractions qui peuvent
être pénales devant le juge jean de
grande instance où ça peut être des
infractions administratives des
sanctions administratives extension
administratif ça peut aller jusqu'à 1500
euros d'amendé amende ou à des
suspensions permis ou des choses comme
ça donc oui c'est bien protégés voilà
une coque ciselés par le temps des
décors à couper le souffle
le pous-tio est redevenu fréquentable et
bénéficie même de subi scientifiques
depuis le balisage la vie sous marine
est de retour et les marins pêcheurs
peut aussi y trouvent leur intérêt
c'est vrai que faut protéger la zone
tour aux produits de cette espèce de
poisson moi je suis d'accord je suis
plus si pour l'avenir n'est que vous la
venue de mes enfants les voient lacanau
que c'est ce qu'il fallait versa on a
fait ce projet de protection de l'air
marine du carpe est en gestation depuis
20 ans est à l'initiative de michel
métairie le compagnon du commandant
cousteau à l'installation technique des
bruits et du balisage a été possible
grâce à des financements publics et
privés nous avons reçu une subvention
fait une gratification de madame
ségolène royal qu'il est devenu lourd
mais il faut dire aussi d'un remercier
les partenaires tous les partenaires
privés qui s'investit qui s'investit
dans ce magnifique chantier est donc
effectivement ça a coûté mais les
partenaires ont amené le surplus ce qui
manque
[Musique]
la ville du carbet plus que jamais
engagée dans un développement durable a
été récompensé par la palme de l'ihf
record une distinction qui récompense
les initiatives de protection du milieu
marin dans la caraïbe la faune du
résinier et du petit on commence tout
juste à renaître mais devra résister aux
événements qui fleurissent de plus en
plus sur l'eau dont le tour des lions
[Musique]